or uh you know with your galentine's
friends hey
gals come on let's don't be down it's
gonna be a great weekend
we've got a few chances for rain we've
got beautiful skies this morning
some gusty winds and pretty mild
temperatures we've pretty much stayed in
the
50s valley wide we are about six degrees
milder this morning than yesterday
thanks to all those southwest winds and
we'll look for a chance of showers which
we're seeing some over northern clark
county right now and this should last
until about noon and then
mostly sunny skies and northwest winds
that will set up for the afternoon
another chance of rain for
saturday afternoon and saturday night
and then a sunny and breezy valentine's
day so here's storm number one that's
just
passing just about on top of us right
now storm number two so you can see
there's not much of a break between
today and what's coming from out in the
pacific
they're both going to move pretty
quickly so showers
snow all moving through california we're
getting the leftovers
and so we are seeing some rain showers
gathering now to the north and the south
of the valley
and along i-15 it's quite windy if
you're traveling but we'll see this rain
if it holds together
we'll be in the north valley
neighborhoods within the half hour
and again we're not looking for
significant rainfall but showers
through the morning hours then mostly
sunny and windy through the afternoon
upper 60s today mid 60s tomorrow
again late day showers tomorrow tomorrow
night and then sunshine
and breezy to windy for valentine's day
clouds for presidents day
lots of 60s through your 8 day forecast
and more sunshine
breezy winds next week